- What's the most important thing,
Emma, I'm gonna ask you first,
what's the most important
lesson, you think,
about motherhood that you
learned from your mother?
- Ooh!
- Oh gosh.
I remember when both my kids were young,
I remember Mom specifically
saying to me, you know,
"Just be patient,
because just when you get
"to that moment where you think,
"I am not gonna be able to survive
"another sleepless night,
or I'm not gonna be able
"to survive this particular
developmental stage,
"just when you think you
can't go another day,
"it will change, and move
on to the next thing."
And it always did.
She was so right about
that, and always, you know--
- [Julie] It is true.
- Just thought,
"Oh my God, I'll never
survive this moment."
(laughing loudly)
They were out of it, and on
to the next thing, you know.
- Well, Julie, we learn
a lot from our kids, too.
I know I do, even from my
four and five year old.
- Always.
- Yeah!
- And they fill in all
the gaps that didn't
make sense when you
were a kid, don't they?
- Wow, that's a really
great way to put it,
I've never thought of it that way.
Well, what's a lesson that you feel
like you've learned from Emma?
- So many things.
I mean, more love than you can imagine.
I mean, I love my kids,
and I didn't particularly
when I was pregnant and things.
I didn't think that I
loved kids that much.
It's a great gift, in every way, yeah.
- I feel like I'm the same way.
I was, my Mom is still surprised
that I married with children.
- Kelly, you have to
mention the other three,
and what their names are, please.
- Oh, yes, oh, I will totally do that,
I have it right here.
And you know what, that's
actually important, 'cause you--
- What do you mean, I have it right here?
You don't remember their--
- I, wait, my kids or yours?
- You have their names
written down or something.
- Oh no, your kids, Kelly, your kids!
- Oh, I thought you were
talking about yours,
I was like, oh my gosh!
- No, no no no, I'm asking you.
- Oh no, I was like, I was
like, I was about to tell you,
it's actually really important for me
that every time I do an interview,
everybody always says, "Oh,
you have two children."
And I'm like, "No, we have four."
I've been in their lives for eight years,
and we're blended, so we,
Savannah's our 18 year old,
she's actually an equestrian,
she does eventing,
and she's actually number
one in her division,
in the country, so she's amazing.
- Wow.
- And then we have our 13 year old, Seth,
he's awesome, he's our little gamer,
and he like does 3D stings, and he,
he just creates, he's
a really creative kid.
- Oh wow.
- And he's actually been
my teleprompter guy for
this whole pandemic,
while I've been--
- There you are,
you see, like Sam is here, helping me.
- You're working Sam,
and I'm working Seth.
Both Biblical names, as well (laughs).
- And the other one?
- River and Remington,
those are the tiny ones,
and they're driving me nuts,
so I could use that patience
talk right now (laughs).
But I was gonna say, I'm like you, though,
I didn't want kids, I didn't
think I'd ever have kids,
and then once you do, you're right, Julie,
like once you do, it teaches
you an amazing amount
of selflessness.
- Yes.
- You know, I didn't realize
how selfish I was, and I--
- The wellspring of love that comes up,
and out of you, I mean,
I now know why people say
I get in front of--
- Like a train, you're right.
- A machine gun,
if it saved my kids, and I would.
- I would do anything for my kids, yeah.
No, I am definitely that.
And we do learn from them every day,
it's funny, you learn, I
think, more about yourself,
and how you act around
them, and you're like,
I could maybe work on that (laughs).